bueno pues lo que estaba ocurriendo es
lo que ya lleva mucho tiempo vaticinando
los expertos cada vez se están
produciendo unas mayores suelas de calor
más intensa en cuanto al valor de la
temperatura con mayor duración en cuanto
al tiempo y con mayor frecuencia a día
de hoy lo que tenemos un anticiclón en
este caso se llama lucifer el anticiclón
un nombre muy apropiado que lo que está
haciendo es la introducción de todo el
calor de toda la calima sahariana el
problema es como comentaba anteriormente
está siendo muy intenso en cuanto a su
temperatura y a su duración y además de
estar actuando sobre toda europa sobre
toda la europa mediterránea la verdad
que estamos consiguiendo una temperatura
con los que no habíamos conocido en la
vida se están consiguiendo temperaturas
de 47 grados 48 grados un verdadero
infierno que nos hiciera estará cómodo
en el claro ello que provoca pues ello
provoca que
a mayor temperatura los que se llaman
las famosas tres tenor el tiempo la
temperatura
y la falta de humedad pues lo que hace
es que provoca la formación de incendios
y si encima la tempera en la velocidad
del viento es muy elevada esto impide
que se sofoque en dicho incendio encima
se une a que muchas veces hay personas
desalmadas que aprovechan estos momentos
para provocar este tipo de evento pues
estamos ardiendo se está ardiendo en
italia si está ardiendo en grecia
en una situación un poco desagradable
pero que como no pongamos un coto a esto
va a seguir aumentando la esperanza que
hace que algunas ciudades tengan más
riesgos que otras y dónde están los
niveles de riesgo de incendios
forestales más altos
en el que una ciudad de sean más
vulnerables que otras depende sobre todo
de su situación geográfica
depende de la sequía o no que haya
sufrido y depende de la cantidad de
pasto que se haya ido generando en el
entorno
ellos como comentaba unido a una
temperatura muy intensa y unido a unas
condiciones de viento
contrarias hace que cualquier incendio
que se produzca no se pueda contener en
sus momentos iniciales y eso ya estamos
hablando de un entorno bastante seco al
entorno mediterráneo el verano es un
clima muy seco entonces si no somos
capaces de parar el incendio en su
momento es primero nos podemos llevar
haciendo todos y tres días ocurrió el
mediterráneo pero ocurre también en
california por ejemplo esperanza cuanto
se ha calentado el mundo en los últimos
años y qué hacer para frenar esto estos
aumentos
bueno pues acaba está saliendo ya sea
esto informe del panel de expertos de
cambio climático el que se llama ipcc y
ponen de manifiesto que ya se ha
aumentado más de 1.5 grado la
temperatura terrestre y además debido a
la actividad humana que es la forma de
proceder para evitarlo por lo primero a
dejar de emitir emisiones de gases
contaminantes de co2 o de metano como se
consigue intentando no utilizar
combustibles fósiles sé que es difícil
pero consiste en reducir
reutilizar reciclar intentar pagar menos
de combustible de todo tipo de energía
que son sumas y lógicamente invirtiendo
mucho en innovación e investigación en
nuevas formas de energía ahí tenemos las
energías renovables que quizás sean una
de las grandes fuentes de las que
tenemos que tirar y en la que ya a día
de hoy tenemos capacidad de invertir en
ella y tenemos un montón de expertos a
su vez analizando otras posibles fuentes
de energía
esperanza caro experta en cambio
climático y calidad del aire muchas
gracias por acompañarnos en france 24
para hablar sobre los efectos del cambio
climático